Trajan: Optimus Princeps
“Felicior Augusto, melior Traiano”.
According to 4th century historian Eutropius,
that was the acclamation used to greet new
Roman emperors in his time.
It expressed hope that the ruler will be “more
fortunate than Augustus and better than Trajan!”
The historian lived 200 years after Trajan,
but the memory of his reign of prosperity
was still very much alive in the hearts and
minds of the Roman people.
Trajan was part of the “Five Good Emperors”
- five successive rulers who presided over
an 85-year period of affluence for the Roman
Empire.
Of those emperors, we can safely say that
Trajan was the best of the bunch.
He enacted welfare policies for the poor,
restored confiscated properties and undertook
numerous construction projects.
Within his borders, he brought stability,
while outwardly, he led military campaigns
which saw the Roman Empire expand to its greatest
size ever.
He became the paragon that all subsequent
emperors aspired to emulate although none
of them reached the same heights.
To honor his accomplishments, the Roman Senate
bestowed upon Trajan the title of “Optimus
Princeps” - “the best ruler”.
Family and Military Life
Trajan was born Marcus Ulpius Traianus on
September 18, 53 CE, in the city of Italica.
This was located in Hispania Baetica, a Roman
province which roughly corresponds to the
modern region of Andalusia in Spain.
This is, in of itself, significant because
Trajan will become the first Roman emperor
to be born outside of Italy.
His father was Marcus Ulpius Traianus the
Elder, a Roman statesman, while his mother
was Marcia, a noblewoman who was the sister-in-law
of Emperor Titus.
He also had an older sister named Ulpia Marciana
who remained very close to her brother throughout
their lives.
Trajan would often consult her as emperor
when making important decisions.
Sometime during his reign, he bestowed upon
Ulpia the imperial title of Augusta, making
her the first sister of a Roman ruler to receive
this honor.
Trajan extended this love and trust to Ulpia’s
daughter, Salonia Matidia, as he himself never
had any children.
After Ulpia’s death, Trajan had her deified
and gave the title of Augusta to his niece.
As a young man, Trajan distinguished himself
with his military service.
He quickly rose through the ranks, undoubtedly
helped by his father’s position and influence.
Sometime around the year 86 CE, his cousin,
Publius Aelius Hadrianus Afer, died and Trajan
became one of the guardians for his two children
- his daughter, Aelia Domitia Paulina, and
his son, Publius Aelius Hadrianus the Younger.
The son would later succeed Trajan to the
throne of Rome as Emperor Hadrian.
Also during this period, he met and married
Pompeia Plotina.
Ancient scholars portrayed her as being a
kind and intelligent woman.
She took an active role during her husband’s
reign, sponsoring initiatives to help the
poor and improve education.
She outlived Trajan by a few years and, when
she passed on, Hadrian built her a temple
and deified her.
Trajan’s military life is poorly documented.
We know that he was successful and well-liked
by his fellow soldiers, something that would
prove vital to his ascent to power later on.
He served as a tribune for 10 or so years,
and traveled to Syria when his father became
governor there.
In 89 CE, Trajan was in command of his own
legion and was sent to either Hispania or
Upper Germania, to put down a coup against
Emperor Domitian.
This earned him the favor of the ruler who
granted Trajan a consulship in 91.
Domitian
In order to get a proper understanding of
Trajan’s rise to the throne, we need a little
background on the two emperors who came before
him: the aforementioned Domitian and Nerva.
Domitian ended up being the last ruler of
the Flavian Dynasty and ancient sources would
have us believe that he was a cruel, ruthless,
and egomaniacal tyrant.
Modern historians tend to disagree, however,
and assert that these characterizations of
the emperor were part of a concentrated effort
to denigrate him after his death.
It is almost certain that Domitian was an
autocrat who ruled with an iron fist and instituted
a cult of personality around himself, but
his totalitarian tendencies were usually focused
on one particular group: the aristocracy of
Rome.
Specifically, he was constantly at odds with
the Senate whose powers the emperor curtailed.
His policies and propaganda actually made
the emperor pretty popular with the people
and the army.
Domitian was assassinated on September 18,
96 CE.
According to Suetonius, he became “an object
of terror and hatred to all” and was the
target of a conspiracy organized by his own
friends and “favorite freedmen”.
The emperor was slain in his chambers where
he was stabbed seven times.
Nerva was crowned the new ruler of Rome and
he immediately began restoring many of the
liberties and privileges taken away by his
predecessor.
Nerva was the first of the so-called “Five
Good Emperors” and, as you would expect,
he did many things to earn this reputation.
He brought people back from exile, put a halt
to treason trials and gave a lot of land to
the poor.
He also instituted numerous policies to save
money such as abolishing many sacrifices and
spectacles, selling large gold and silver
statues commissioned by Domitian and forbidding
that any such sculptures should be made in
his own honor.
Although Nerva was popular with the people
and the Senate, he failed to appease the army
where support for Domitian was still strong.
The Praetorian Guard demanded that the conspirators
who assassinated the previous emperor be executed,
but Nerva refused.
A quick side note here to give a little historical
context on how important it was for an emperor
to have the approval of the Praetorian Guard.
Although they began as an elite military unit,
they became the emperor’s personal bodyguards
under Augustus.
From there, they kept growing in size and
influence until they turned into the de facto
police force of Rome.
There have been quite a few intrigues and
assassinations where the Guard played a vital
role.
Maybe we’ll talk about a few of them some
day.
On one particularly egregious occasion, the
Praetorian Guard killed the emperor and then,
effectively, sold the throne of Rome by granting
their support to the highest bidder.
This happened in 193 CE when they killed Pertinax
and accepted an offer of 25,000 sesterces
each to make Didius Julianus the new Emperor
of Rome.
His reign lasted a whopping 66 days before
he was also assassinated.
Back to Nerva, there was another problem with
his reign - he was old and in poor health.
He was 66 years old when he took the throne
and had no children or close relatives.
The discontent of the army plus the lack of
a clear successor pretty much guaranteed a
civil war upon his death.
In an attempt to pacify the soldiers, Nerva
assigned command of the Praetorian Guard to
Casperius Aelianus who served as praetorian
prefect under Domitian.
This tactic backfired because Aelianus incited
the men to get justice for their former emperor.
In July or August 97 CE, the Praetorian Guard
lay siege to the imperial palace, took the
men responsible for Domitian’s death by
force and executed them.
Nerva was not harmed, but his authority was
in tatters.
Only one thing could help him keep his position
- naming an heir who was popular with the
people, the army, and
the Senate.
That heir was Trajan.
Rise to
the Throne
Trajan’s appointment came just in time.
He was named heir in October 97 CE.
A few months later, on January 27, Nerva died
of natural causes after 15 months as emperor.
Trajan, who was governor of Germania Inferior
when he heard the news, was in no hurry to
get to Rome to start his new career, instead
taking a lengthy tour of the empire’s frontiers.
Scholars had suggested he did this to ensure
he had the loyalty of the soldiers across
the Roman domain.
He did see fit to deal with the praetorians
who revolted against Nerva, though.
He sent for Aelianus and the rest of the mutineers
to come to Germany for special employment
and there, according to Cassius Dio, he “put
them out of the way”.
It wasn’t until the summer of 99 CE that
Trajan finally set foot in Rome as emperor.
Dio takes the opportunity here to compliment
Plotina, Trajan’s wife, who, upon entering
the palace for the first time, turned around
to the crowd and said “I enter here such
a woman as I would fain be when I depart”.
And, indeed, according to the historian, she
exhibited behavior beyond reproach during
the entire reign.
The Dacian Wars
As emperor, Trajan first turned his attention
to Dacia, a kingdom that mostly corresponds
to modern-day Romania and Moldova.
Dacia had been a nuisance to Rome, on and
off, for a few centuries.
During the mid 1st century BCE, a powerful
Dacian king called Burebista had united all
the various tribes under his rule.
Caesar was planning to lead a campaign there,
but was killed in 44 BCE.
However, Burebista was assassinated that same
year and the kingdom slowly splintered after
his death.
It wasn’t until over a century later that
it reemerged as a menace under King Duras
and attacked the Roman province of Moesia.
Domitian was emperor at the time.
He had to respond to this invasion so he launched
the First Dacian War.
In 87 CE, a Roman army led by General Cornelius
Fuscus crossed the Danube and suffered a humiliating
loss at Tapae.
The next year, a renewed offensive was more
successful, but Domitian still had to accept
peace on favorable terms to the Dacians because
his army was needed someplace else to put
down a rebellion.
The new Dacian King Decebalus might have declared
himself a client of Rome but, in exchange,
he received money and craftsmen which he used
to improve Dacia’s defenses and arm its
soldiers.
For decades, this peace was a bit of an embarrassment
for the mighty Roman Empire, especially since
the Dacians still liked to carry on border
raids from time to time.
Cassius Dio described Decebalus as a “worthy
antagonist of the Romans”, a king who was
“shrewd in his understanding of warfare”,
and a “master in pitched battles”.
Clearly, Trajan agreed because he saw it necessary
to deal with the threat once and for all and
restore some of the glory lost during Domitian’s
failed campaign.
Trajan got the Senate’s blessing to go to
war and, in 101 CE, the Roman army crossed
the Danube River once again and invaded Dacia.
The Roman Emperor obtained a major victory
over Decebalus at the Second Battle of Tapae.
A few more minor conflicts followed but, in
the end, Trajan decided to sue for peace because
he didn’t want his army to get caught in
Dacia during winter.
This time, though, the terms were considerably
in Rome’s favor.
Among other concessions, the Dacians had to
build a stone bridge over the Danube which
would make it a lot easier for Roman troops
to cross the river should they invade Dacia
again.
This structure, simply known as Trajan’s
Bridge, was considered quite a marvel of its
time.
It was designed by a brilliant Greek architect
called Apollodorus of Damascus who would also
be responsible for other constructions ordered
by Trajan.
The bridge only stayed functional for a few
decades until Emperor Aurelian destroyed it,
but it remained the longest bridge of its
kind for over 1,000 years.
There was peace, but Trajan understood that
it was only a moment of respite until the
Dacians regained their strength.
In 105 CE, the two sides went to war again.
This time, the fighting was more neck and
neck as the Romans struggled to gain a decisive
victory.
In 106, they laid siege to the Dacian capital
of Sarmizegetusa and eventually forced the
people inside to surrender by destroying their
water supply.
Afterwards, the capital was razed to the ground.
Decebalus committed suicide instead of being
taken prisoner and his head was brought back
to Rome.
Half of Dacia was annexed as a Roman province
while the other half remained free but consisted
of tribes that never united again.
The land had rich gold mines which provided
a great boost to the Roman economy, not to
mention the tens of thousands of slaves who
were sent back to Rome.
A few years later, Trajan’s victory in the
Dacian Wars was commemorated in a triumphal
monument called Trajan’s Column which still
stands today in Rome.
It is 115 feet tall and has a spiral bas relief
which depicts all the important events from
the wars.
It is, actually, the only source we have for
some aspects of the conflict and historians
still debate if it is historically accurate
or intended more as a propaganda piece.
The Roman emperor also put down his version
of the story into writing.
Inspired by Commentarii de Bello Gallico,
Julius Caesar’s firsthand account of his
wars with the Gauls, Trajan wrote De bello
dacico.
Unfortunately, the book is lost to history
except for just one sentence which was quoted
in a different work - inde Berzobim, deinde
Aizi processimus.
It means “We advanced to Berzobis, and then
to Aizi”.
Work in Rome
Shortly after his triumph, Trajan had an opportunity
to add the Nabataean Kingdom to his empire.
This was significantly different from the
fights he had with the Dacians.
It was already a client-state of Rome and,
after King Rabel II Soter died in 106, all
it took was to move in two legions from nearby
provinces.
We don’t know specifics about the conquest,
but it seems that the troops encountered almost
no resistance.
Thus, the Nabataean Kingdom came to an end
as it was turned into a Roman province called
Arabia Petraea.
The next few years of Trajan’s reign were
peaceful and they allowed the emperor to focus
his attention on improving things back home.
He had 123 days of games and festivities to
celebrate his victory in the Dacian Wars.
He built and improved roads and bridges such
as the 205-mile Via Traiana which can still
be partially found on the road between Benevento
and Brindisi.
In Rome, he put Apollodorus of Damascus’s
talents to good use.
The architect designed and constructed a new
market, baths and a forum which would become
the last of the Imperial fora built in ancient
Rome.
The only improvement they could have used
was a bit more creativity with the names.
Predictably, they were called Trajan’s Market,
the Baths of Trajan, and Trajan’s Forum.
Other constructions ordered by the emperor
included libraries, aqueducts, temples, and
a renovation of the Circus Maximus which saw
it rebuilt entirely in stone.
Cassius Dio mentions in passing that Trajan
was the target of several plots against him.
He only names one conspirator as Crassus.
Obviously, these conspiracies failed and the
emperor brought Crassus before the Senate
to be punished.
What exactly happened to him and his co-conspirators
remains a mystery as the historian specifies
that Trajan made an oath not to shed blood
(by which he meant Roman blood, of course)
and that he kept this vow.
The Parthian War Begins
In 113 CE, Trajan entered conflict with the
Parthian Empire, a powerful entity located
in ancient Iran.
Like Dacia, Parthia had long been a thorn
in Rome’s side as clashes between the two
domains went back centuries.
Also like Dacia, Trajan sought to be the one
to solve this problem permanently and enjoy
the renown and acclamations that would come
with it.
In fact, the emperor’s complete, true motives
remain somewhat of a hot topic among Roman
historians.
Some see them as being practical.
Trajan wanted to strengthen the defenses of
his eastern frontier and benefit from the
economic boost of adding Parthia to the Roman
Empire.
Others believe it was simply in his nature.
Trajan was a military man, first and foremost,
and would have likely gone on warring as long
as he could.
And some opine that Trajan wanted to emulate
the conquests of Alexander the Great and secure
for himself the near-divine status that the
latter enjoyed.
Whatever the reason, in 113 CE, Trajan marched,
leaving Rome, never to return again.
Located between the two empires was the Kingdom
of Armenia.
Although technically independent, it fell
under the hegemony of both Rome and Parthia
and both powers had a vested interest in ensuring
that the ruler of Armenia was on their side.
In 110 CE, the Parthian Prince Axidares was
installed as King of Armenia by his uncle,
King Osroes I of Parthia, without Roman approval.
On his way to Armenia, Trajan met an embassy
from the Parthian king.
In an attempt to appease Rome, Osroes had
deposed Axidares and installed his brother,
Parthamasiris, as new ruler of Armenia and
sought Trajan’s approval for this change.
Why exactly he thought the emperor would be
ok with one brother, but not the other, we
don’t know.
Trajan was gracious to his guests but mostly
ignored their requests and kept on marching.
The conquest of Armenia was quick and bloodless.
King Parthamasiris entered Trajan’s camp,
took his diadem off his head and surrendered
it to the emperor.
He fully expected to get it back and become
a client-king of Rome in a move reminiscent
of what Nero did with King Tiridates half
a century prior.
Instead, Trajan kept Armenia as a new Roman
province and installed a governor to rule.
Parthamasiris died soon after and, although
the circumstances are not known, some have
speculated he was killed on Trajan’s orders.
The Mesopotamian Campaign
In 115 CE, the emperor launched his Mesopotamian
campaign, although the exact order of events
is unclear from ancient sources.
Besides the Parthian Empire, the region was
full of small kingdoms and city-states with
kings and satraps alike sending gifts and
envoys to ensure they obtained the favor of
Rome.
Trajan split his army into divisions that
went after multiple targets.
He was then able to capture, in quick succession,
Adiabene, Babylon, Charax, and Seleucia, culminating
with the conquest of the Parthian capital
of Ctesiphon.
At this point, the Roman Empire reached its
greatest size in history.
Cassius Dio writes that Trajan was tempted
to march into India, like Alexander the Great
did, but concluded that he was getting too
old for this thing.
Instead, he was content with making a trip
to Babylon and offering sacrifice in the house
where Alexander died.
He did make sure to specify in writing to
the Senate, though, that he advanced further
than Alexander, although keeping his new possessions
proved to be a problem.
When Trajan left, many of the domains he conquered
began rebelling and the garrisons that stayed
behind were not enough to maintain control.
It is also at this time that the emperor’s
health started to decline and some historians
believe he might have suffered heat stroke
while laying siege to the city of Hatra.
To make matters worse, Jewish populations
in multiple regions such as Cyrene and Egypt
began uprising and Trajan had no choice but
to divert armies to deal with these revolts.
Death
Trajan hoped that this would be a minor setback.
He left his troops in charge of his generals
and set sail for Italy to regain his health.
He then planned to return, take command again
and settle any conflicts that remained.
That’s not how things panned out.
He died suddenly on August 8, 117 CE, aged
63, in the port-town of Selinus in modern-day
Turkey.
His cause of death remains somewhat controversial.
Some sources say he died of a stroke, although
both modern and ancient historians made mention
of poison.
His succession was also a bit contentious.
His cousin Hadrian followed him on the throne,
but whether Trajan actually named him as his
heir or this was arranged by his wife Plotina
after his death remains debatable.
One of Hadrian’s first acts was to pull
out of Mesopotamia as it became clear that
Rome did not have the resources to keep the
region.
Trajan might have ultimately failed in his
Parthian campaign, but he left behind a cherished
legacy that is still celebrated today.